Salut, aujourd'hui on est samedi, c'est donc le deuxième master class.
Master class, c'est la classe !
Mercredi, je vous avais demandé des idées d'astuce pour l'astuce de la semaine.
Vous m'en avez donné plein et vous m'avez donné cette idée de master class.
Quelles sont les bonnes choses à savoir pour avoir un entretien d'embauche qui se passe bien ?
J'ai décliné ça en 5 points mais en fait, dans les 5 points,  des fois il y a 3 points en sous-points.
Et des fois dans les 3 points en sous-points il y a des sous sous sous sous-points.
Mon premier conseil parait logique mais il est pas si évident que ça apparemment de ce que je sais des recruteurs.
C'est renseignez vous vraiment sur l'entreprise où vous allez postuler.
Ça veut dire bien connaitre l'entreprise.
Ça veut dire se renseigner un petit peu sur internet à l'avance  pour connaitre l'actu de celle-ci.
Est ce qu'elle a eu un prix récemment ? Est qu'elle a sorti un nouveau produit ?
Quelles sont ses valeurs fondamentales ?
Qui a créé l'entreprise ? Pourquoi elle a été créée ?
Essayer d'en savoir un maximum.
Montrez vous intéressé parce cette entreprise,
il y a de grandes chances que ce soit la grande passion de votre passion et que lui, il connaisse ça par coeur.
En parlant d'apprendre ça par coeur,
souvent, ces sociétés, elles ont un petit guide, un petit descriptif
qui parle de la boîte, qui parle de l'actu de la boîte.
Des fois c'est un magazine en interne, des fois c'est quelque chose qu'on peut avoir à l'extérieur.
Essayez de vous le procurer, même à la dernière seconde
même quand vous êtes dans la salle d'attente en train d'attendre votre entretien.
Pourquoi ? Parce que grâce au master class de la semaine dernière,
vous allez pouvoir mémoriser un maximum d'informations.
Vous essayez de retenir un élément par page grâce à vos images mentales
cf master class de la semaine dernière
Et lors de votre entretien ou de votre conversation avec le DRH ou la personne qui va vous recevoir,
vous allez pouvoir faire référence à ce petit livret ou à ce petit bouquin
en disant "oui tout à fait comme le traite la page 7 du magazine en interne,
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec Monsieur Tamalo qui dit "il faut ouvrir la fenêtre pour que je puisse sortir".
C'est une nouvelle réforme.
Deuxième conseil : ayez une attitude positive et surtout proactive.
Une attitude proactive. Alors, qu'est ce que ça veut dire proactif ?
Ça veut dire que vous allez aller de l'avant.
Par exemple, vous pouvez reformuler les questions que le recruteur vous demande.
Ça montre déjà que vous avez compris,  ça vous fait gagner un petit peu de temps sur la réponse,
et surtout, ça lui montre que vous l'écoutez.
Puisque quand on est capable de traduire une idée différemment avec d'autres mots,
c'est qu'on est à l'écoute de la personne.
Et ça, ça se remarque.
Prenez des notes.
J'ai eu la chance dans ma vie de parler souvent avec des décideurs ou des dirigeants en entreprises
et quelque chose qui est revenu souvent revenu à mes oreilles,
je ne sais pas si c'est un conseil qui est connu ou pas,
c'est que les personnes qui passent des entretiens ne prennent jamais de notes.
Ils ont l'air très intéressés, ils font oui oui de la tête tout le temps,
mais ils ne notent jamais rien sur toute la masse d'informations.
Et on le sait qu'on peut pas tout retenir.
Ben oui sinon je ferais pas des vidéos comme ça
et je suis encore une fois beaucoup trop près.
Si vous prenez des notes, c'est pas discourtois.
au contraire, ça montre que vous êtes engagé, intéressé et que vous voulez bien faire votre travail.
Et être proactif, c'est aussi créer une relation avec la personne,
créer un vrai échange un petit peu d'égal à égal
sans se tromper sur qui est le recruteur et quelle est votre place à ce moment là de la conversation
mais n'hésitez pas à renvoyer des questions quand on vous donne la main.
Si à un moment donné, le recruteur vous dit "vous avez peut-être des questions sur l'entreprise ?"
reprenez la main en demandant simplement si lui a envie que vous approfondissiez quelques points de votre CV
ou sur des choses que vous avez dit aujourd'hui.
Le 3ème conseil, il se passe avec ça.
Il se passe avec vos mains.
1er point, c'est bien sûr la classique poignée de main.
Quand on sert la main à quelqu'un, surtout quand c'est pour la première fois,
ça veut toujours dire quelque chose.
Attention à ne pas avoir les mains moites, évidemment.
Vous faites une poignée franche.
Pas trop appuyée non plus, faut pas qu'on pense que vous essayez de prendre le pouvoir ou ce genre de chose.
Une main déterminée en fait : franche et pas moite.
si elles sont moites, si vous transpirez, essuyez vous avant.
Quand vous parlez au recruteur, vous pouvez évidemment parler un petit peu avec vos mains,
accompagner vos gestes de mains sans trop exagérer quand même.
Ça montre que vous n'êtes pas en train de réciter et que vous êtes à fond dans votre discours.
Tu vois là je suis à fond !
Mais quand vous êtes en écoute, il va falloir penser à contrôler vos mains.
Déjà, vous aurez de la chance parce que vous êtes assis.
donc on fait moins de bêtises avec son corps une fois qu'on est assis.
Et pour les mains on va faire pareil.
Si vous êtes très proche du bureau,
vous posez vos mains sur le bureau ou vos coudes sur le bureau.
Si vous avez des accoudoirs un petit peu comme j'ai là sur le siège,
vous posez vos bras sur les accoudoirs.
Si vous n'avez pas d'accoudoir, si il n'y a pas de bureau,
vous posez vos mains juste sur vos genoux.
Et si vous n'avez pas de genou ...pfff
Pensez à respecter ce contact permanent,
essayez de ne pas vous décoller
et ça évitera de bouger, de se gratter,
d'avoir des gestes parasites, de remettre un truc, de se recoiffer,
tous ces éléments qui vont pas jouer en votre faveur.
On arrive déjà à notre 4ème conseil.
oui c'est un master class rapide.
J'ai une petite annonce à faire avant le 4ème conseil :
Si vous êtes un site, si vous êtes un blog, si vous êtes un journal
et que vous voulez relayer mes informations, redonner mes conseils par écrit,
vous pouvez faire tout ça, vraiment ça me fait plaisir.
Par contre, pensez à me citer et à mettre la vidéo dans votre article.
Le 4ème conseil c'est l'observation.
Observe.
Parce que , ok, le recruteur va vous observer.
Il va regarder par exemple si vous croisez pas les bras, si vous croisez pas les jambes.
Ce sont des signes d'enfermement.
Ça veut dire que vous êtes contre quelque chose, ça veut dire que vous avez une retenue.
C'est pour ça que je vous fais poser les mains etc.
pour pas avoir ces gestes là parasites
Mais vous, vous pouvez en apprendre beaucoup sur le recruteur,
sur ce qu'il attend de vous et dans quel état mental il est au moment où il vous parle.
Ça, c'est hyper intéressant.
Ça permet par exemple de réorienter votre discours.
Ça permet aussi de redynamiser les choses
ou tout simplement de changer de sujet si vous sentez que c'est plus le moment.
Déjà, analysons ce recruteur.
Si par exemple, il vous parle comme ça avec son profil gauche.
Oui, je vous rappelle que c'est mon profil gauche : la caméra, ça inverse, évidemment.
Alors, ça veut dire que votre recruteur est plutôt dans la spontanéité, dans la confiance, dans le lien
dans l'énergie qu'on peut trouver un peu dans les start up.
Donc c'est plutôt quelqu'un à la cool, qui va chercher la franchise.
Vous pouvez l'aborder assez naturellement
Ne soyez pas trop rigide.
S'il vous parle du côté du profil droit, ça veut dire qu'il est dans l'analyse.
Ça veut dire que c'est quelqu'un de cartésien, quelqu'un de très rationnel.
Il est en train d'écouter ce que vous dites, il est en train d'analyser le moindre mot.
Attention de toujours prendre le temps de bien parler, en articulant.
Ça vous fera gagner du temps pour anticiper les phrases que vous allez dire
et pas vous faire piéger parce que lui, il va tout retenir.
Votre recruteur aussi a les mains qui bougent quand il vous parle. Et bien là c'est pareil.
Si c'est la main gauche qui bouge, ça veut dire de la même manière
qu'à ce moment là de la conversation, il est dans la spontanéité, il est plutôt dans l'émotionnel
dans des choses qui le touchent. Il est bien avec vous.
Il vous parle de quelque chose qui lui tient à coeur.
Si vous voulez vous en souvenir, le côté gauche d'ailleurs, c'est le côté du coeur.
S'il vous parle plus avec la main droite,
c'est qu'encore une fois, il est dans l'analyse, dans la réflexion pure.
C'est un cérébral pur et dur, cartésien.
Mais ses yeux, vous aviez regardé ses yeux ?
C'est une mine d'information.
Déjà, il y a un conseil de base, c'est de le regarder toujours dans les yeux, d'être le moins fuyant possible.
Essayer quand même de ne pas être trop insistant
parce que ça, ça fait flipper :
moi, j'engagerai pas quelqu'un qui me regarde comme ça pendant 20 minutes quand même.
Donc vous le regardez bien dans les yeux mais sans être un psycho non plus.
S'il vous sourit, ça veut pas dire non plus qu'il sourit.
Ça vous le saurez grâce aux yeux uniquement.
Vous regardez s'il y a bien tous les plis du vrai sourire au niveau des yeux.
Par exemple, je peux sourire : c'est pas un sourire tranquille, tranquille.
En tous cas il se passait rien ici.
Quand on pense vraiment à un truc drôle, là on a des choses qui se passent ici.
Ça commence à plisser réellement.
Ça vous montre si vous avez percé quelque chose ou si la personne est juste polie et joviale.
Et le fait de faire tout ça, ça va aussi vous permettre de regarder la dilatation de la rétine de la personne.
Les micro mouvements dilatoires de la rétine.
C'est intéressant et ça se voit.
Essayez de bien observer
De temps en temps, vous savez que vous allez lâcher des points importants, des choses essentielles.
Il y en a qui vont faire mouche plus que les autres.
Ça va Tamalo ? Lui, il chasse la mouche, c'est différent.
Il y a donc des choses qui vont taper plus fort que les autres.
Et ça vous allez le savoir avec la dilatation de la rétine.
Vous allez juste savoir si ça a provoqué de l'intérêt en fait.
Une sorte d'excitation en lui, de l'intérêt.
Si c'est le cas, ça veut dire qu'il va falloir développer, va falloir accentuer sur ces points là.
Enfin, ce que j'ai placé comme 5ème conseil,
enfin, du moins, tout ce que j'ai mis dans le 5ème conseil,
ça concerne l'ennui : l'ennui de votre recruteur,
qui en a marre, mais alors marre
d'entendre les mêmes choses et de voir les gens qui lui répètent et qui lui parlent.
Il faut forcément essayer de susciter son intérêt.
Pour ça, y a pas de secret, il faut essayer d'adapter son discours tout le temps.
Adapter, changer de route, aller à droite, à gauche , peu importe.
En repérant les signes de l'ennui évidemment.
On pense qu'une personne, plus elle est en arrière comme ça, plus elle est détendue.
C'est complètement faux.
Plus le recruteur se mettra avachi à l'arrière dans sa conversation,
plus il va vouloir mettre une distance entre vous et lui.
C'est ce qu'il est en train de faire physiquement,
mais c'est aussi ce qu'il est en train de faire mentalement.
Dans ces cas là, c'est pas tout à fait bon signe, il faut changer de direction.
Par contre, s'il penche le corps légèrement en avant vers vous,
voire même s'il pose les coudes sur la table pour s'approcher de vous,
ça veut dire que c'est une personne très bienveillante
qui est vraiment en train de vous écouter, qui est vraiment ouverte.
C'est le seul cas où des bras croisés peuvent être un signe d'ouverture.
Parce qu'à ce moment là d'ailleurs, ça sert de soutien simplement au corps,
pour pouvoir s'approcher de vous et bien vous écouter.
Egalement, si la personne fronce des sourcils pendant que vous parlez,
pendant qu'elle est en situation d'écoute.
Si la personne fronce des sourcils alors que c'est pas quelque chose de compliqué à comprendre ce que vous expliquez
c'est pas forcément comme ça,
il faut que vous preniez l'habitude de détecter les petites variations,
ça veut dire encore une fois qu'il faut changer de piste,
vous êtes pas sur le bon sujet de conversation.
Squeezez, raccourcissez, inutile de développer même si c'était à la base une question que lui avait posée.
Ça veut pas dire que la réponse que vous faites est digne d'intérêt donc
il faut optimiser votre temps.
Optimisation !
Et pourquoi je chante ?
Et ben je sais pas !
Et enfin parce que ça, c'est toujours bon à savoir,
si la personne se gratte souvent
quand elle est en situation d'écoute, là je parle toujours de ce moment là
si elle se gratte, si elle se repositionne,
si elle prend un stylo pour le remettre,
tout ça, ce sont des signes d'ennui.
Même quand c'est le fait de se gratter, de se moucher, de se repositionner
en fait le corps envoie des signaux pour  distraire un petit peu l'esprit
ou tout du moins pour lui rappeler qu'il est en train de s'ennuyer fermement.
Si vous détectez ça, 2-3 d'affilé,
pensez encore une fois à peut-être vous vous repositionner déjà, sur votre siège,
à changer de sujet de conversation
à poser une question parce que ça, c'est la relance et la relance, ça c'est bon.
Et voilà, je vous ai donné une quinzaine de points qui vont vous aider
à améliorer et à optimiser vos entretiens d'embauche.
C'était un master class spécial entretien d'embauche.
C'est sûrement le master class numéro 1 là dessus.
Je pense qu'il serait intéressant que j'en fasse 1 -2.
On a une année pour le faire. Ce serait pas mal. Dites moi.
On va faire ça. Dites moi simplement si ça vous intéresserait que j'en refasse un pour approfondir.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, pensez à la partager un petit peu partout.
Propagez la bonne parole du mental vlog.
Ça peut vraiment intéresser quelqu'un qui va passer un entretien d'embauche.
Mettez le sur votre mur, partagez le.
Mettez un petit pouce en l'air, abonnez vous à la chaîne YouTube.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain mental vlog. Ciao !